a sustainable world's already been
invented
life's technologies tend to be elegant
they sip energy they shave material use
they really avoid toxins those are all
the things we're looking for these days
it's as if you were tapping into an R&D
lab that you could never afford and that
has been going on for 3.8 billion years
I'm Janine Benyus I'm a natural history
writer and I had written five books how
organisms are uniquely adapt and to
excel in their environments looking at
nature's technologies all day long I
thought life is the consummate engineer
consummate chemists consummate
physicists there must be a field in
which inventors look to the natural
world for inspiration but in 1990 it
didn't even have a name so I gave it the
name biomimicry innovation inspired by
Nature
time after time of these twenty years
I've seen this sort of paradigm flip of
brand new ways to to look at a problem
one of the things life has to do is it
has to move fluids like air water with a
minimum of friction
why don't we allow fluids to travel in
the way that they most want to travel
without friction
so one of the advantages of using
energy-efficient design like biomimicry
is we can engineer a product that's far
smaller than competitive products now
that means we use less material
it means our motors use less power the
same design principles that Nature has
been using for billions of years by the
design principles that we distilled into
the lily impeller it simulates and
imitates the same vortical flow that
you'd experience in nature and imposes
it on a body of fluid that's the same
structure that you see vortexes at all
scales you can see it at the scale of
tiny microscopic features you can see it
all the way up into the scale of
cyclones operating the pacific nature
keeps coming back to the same patterns
over and over again and it must be
because those patterns are successful
the lily impeller even though it's so
small actually can mix tanks as large as
seventeen gallons of water we have
thousands of our units in water systems
around the United States and around the
world so we're really beginning to show
people the global potential for
biomimetic energy efficiency
this is an amazing assemblage of
technologies right here in the street
you're seeing in three dimensions a
water distribution system that is so
efficient and so effective it takes very
very little energy if you try to build
this from from an engineer's perspective
you'd put a you'd put a big mechanical
room down below right with a big engine
this is run by the power of the Sun
every green thing that you see on this
planet is made of carbon dioxide and in
the oceans coral reefs actually pull co2
in making of reef is a co2 sequestering
process so we're mimicking what nature
does at the grandest scale what we're
doing now is taking carbon dioxide that
would have gone into the atmosphere and
instead we're doing what corals do they
were converting it into a limestone 71%
of all aggregate used in concrete is
limestone
the fundamental value
and studying nature and then doing the
engineering it's extremely powerful
life creates conditions conducive to
life
and what's happening in the design
professions is that that's becoming part
of the design part of every design group
it's no longer green design it's just
good design